former senator dean heller making  headlines recalling joe biden an  illegitimate president heller is now  among the front-runners in a republican  primary for governor and during an  interview with politics now's john  langler heller doubled down and claimed  there was fraud in the 2020 election  secretary of state for 12 years here i  know our election laws i know what it  means to to to to mail a ballot to  everybody but not have clean voter rolls  when you walk into apartment complex and  you see a hundred ballots on the ground  and you say no there's no there's no  voter fraud there  now current republican secretary of  state barbara sagaski has repeatedly  said there was no widespread fraud in  the 2020 election heller is running to  unseat our current governor steve  sisilak you can catch more of that  interview with dean haller along with  other candidates on politics now it's  this saturday at 11 35 in the evening  right after our late news